I was so honored and delighted
to be awarded this prize
by the Library of Congress
because the library
of Congress is a place
very dear to my heart.
It's a place where
I have done research
since the very beginning
of my career as a historian
and I find a libraries
and archives
to be something rather magical.
I always feel as if I
get into a time machine
and can really delve back into
another era and another kind
of understanding of the
Human Condition Library
of Congress has had a number
of very significant
contributions to my work.
One, perhaps the best
known of the kinds
of materials I used
are the photographs,
the civil war photographs, which
are such a rich resource now.
Many of the best
known civil war images
in the library's collections
are the ones of the bodies
on the battlefields, the
gardener and Brady photographs.
But in my book about death,
I found a lot of images
that I hadn't been
familiar with before
about other dimensions of death.
Embalmers on the battlefield or
grave diggers working together
or a whole other set of visual
representations of things
that I had been finding
in words in my research,
so that was a marvelous
treasure that the library
of Congress unlocked
for me, but a manual set
of manuscripts also are one
of my favorite elements
of that book.
Manuscripts that are in
the library congress.
Most of the papers of Clara
Barton, the battlefield nurse
who kept extensive records of
her experiences during the war
and also was very involved
in some of the issues
about identifying the dead
and honoring the dead that are
at the core of my work in
this Republic of suffering.
And I remember one of the most
moving things in the collection
for me was a set of
little notebooks,
very small in which she
would write down information
that patients would tell her
as she was serving them
with their addresses.
Next of kin.
And knowing what I did about
the high level of mortality
and the lack of dog tags
or other identification.
I'm sure that she kept
this information so that
if an individual died or if
she wished to communicate
for some other reason with the
family, she was able to do that
and and they were just the right
size to keep in our pocket.
So I could imagine her moving
about the civil war hospital
with this little notebook now
in the library of Congress,
in her pocket, in her hands
as she undertook the work.
Not just of medical service
and care for these individuals,
but trying to care
for their families.
Those around them who might
never otherwise know what the
fate of their loved
ones had been.
So the very physicality of those
books meant a great deal to me.
And that's part of the
library of Congress's wonders.